tell me about this look tonight this
look is just a little best from my
friend our gate are getting she gave it
to me and I was like it's the best day
you know it's 2:00 p.m. it's day drag so
I'm trying to hide like the square
features with some bangs it's really lit
in here
and it's very warm it's like Hunger
Games lit like all the lights and on a
drag queen or in the day I'm praying so
I need to see the bag okay do you want
to take it off and explain it to us I
got hairspray I got not a fan we got the
screener of stars born I'm gonna get
Gaga to sign it because I'm a fan I'm
that girl I'm like gaga hey how you
doing I love you will you sign this
she's amazing some nails extra nails
just in case get a sponsor what does
this mean you're here with all the other
fellow actors and being so celebrated
Yeah right it's so cool for them to like
show drag in a movie like this and for
the movie to be good and for it to like
actually be like what drag is like right
now in a dressing room just girls like
key keying and stuff it's really cool
and Bradley was like amazing for just
letting us like play yeah are you upset
about his Best Director snub at the
Oscars come on I think he's a great
director I mean he to be in a scene and
to directed and to like improv with
people and to be so [ __ ] like he's
like the yes and like he said yes to
everything I'm like son my tits yeah
stay here you know like it's one of
those things and it's just playing with
someone in the scene and then you
realize he's the [ __ ] director too
like girl he's turning it he was
everything and I love I I'd love to be
directed by him again he's great now
Lady Gaga told us she's very hoarse
because as a lot of the world saw a show
last night girl she's flying in she's
flying it she flies down with a mirrored
guitar or keytar and then she does just
dance and then she
chances she does a whole show and then
she wakes up and then comes here I know
how long it took me to get ready she's
flying too and she just did a gig last
night girl I bowed down God is a gaga
God is a gaga
we did bring her a little treat I want
to show you what we have for her look at
this look what we brought for her or do
you bet on I hate them to have these
these ones are from Agha I need to stop
cursing it's not just Hollywood I'm
sorry I mean it's fine yes I'm so happy
my last thing I want to happen I want to
ask you this what do you think of the
shocking elimination of Valentin on drag
race this Friday oh my gosh she got
kicked off the show on Friday and then
she's dying and rent on Sunday but I
said the dress when she's sickening I
saw it on Friday I've saw from the pit I
was like yeah it's my friend Emerson's
in it too he's the waiter
yeah it's sickening mal Jean is amazing
[Music]